tem uma música do skank que dias é
improvável
é quase impossível amar alguém viver
feliz em ter alguém para amar e que
quase uma imposição quase uma em
obrigação e se ter alguém viver apa
mas o que a realização dos rios quase
uma imposição tara que ele só vou se
você for não é um desejo quase uma
obrigação
todas as religiões todos os credos
acreditando deus que for acabam
sacralizando um casamento para as
pessoas viverem juntos para sempre até à
morte para se reproduzirem ainda que
seja na tristeza na doença ou na pobreza
quase uma da nação
as pessoas são obrigadas a casar num
encontrar alguém se não tiver um pa
se for uma mulher koita sobrou ficou
para titia
se for um menino aeg não tem dúvida
nenhuma que é esquisito e um quiz casa
só pode ser gay
além de o verso obrigação de casar não
existe nem a liberdade de escolher com
quem por que necessariamente sempre um
par
o homem tem que ser em tudo mais
ele tem que ser mais alto ele tem que
ser mais velho ele tem que ganhar mais
ele tem que saber mais e têm que ser
mais curto e o sinal - fica sempre a
mulher
e claro e para cumprir aquele preceito
do crescei e multiplicai vos um pato tem
que ser de sexos diferentes
a não ser por este motivo confesso que
eu não entendo qual é a justificativa de
haver tanta rejeição tanto ódio tanta
versão quando o amor das pessoas não se
dirigem a pessoa do outro sexo e família
à escola trabalho vizinho sociedade todo
mundo tem uma repulsa perversa com
relação às uniões de pessoas do mesmo
sexo
esta repulsa tão significativo aqui no
brasil gente a cada 28 horas sexual é
morto em função da sua e identidade
sexual ou de gênero
este número não é oficial porque o
estado não se preocupe em quantificar é
resultado de um trabalho de uma ong que
pelas notícias do jornal e todo mundo
envia luiz mott ele foi contando os que
não se contam e eu falei morte gente
realizam a agressão a discriminação tem
que contar pra vocês
quando eu estive no shopping no rio de
janeiro como o quinto marido porque eu
gosto tanto nela diz é o ponto por
número e eu estava com um amigo gay
porque eu tinha de fazer uma palestra
enfim eu encontrei uma loja maravilhosa
que não tinha na minha cidade e não
agora eu vou experimentar umas roupinhas
aqui e vocês vão fazer qualquer coisa na
praça alimentação tomar refrigerante e ó
é distraída na loja quando eu vi
voltaram os dois
o meu marido da vez era um senhor cabeça
branca professor
o outro menino chamava ele de professor
o tratava como tal a carne da onda não
terminei não vou ficar aqui na saída
assim pela primeira vez eu entendi o
porquê da sua luta há porque se tal
movimento a censura porque sempre nas
costas apanhamos na praça de alimentação
de um shopping no rio de janeiro quando
a coca cola um senhor e um jovem
o chamado voto de professor e eu fiquei
com medo e por isso que nós viemos pra
cá a gente mundo perverso é esse que nós
conseguimos não conseguir conviver com o
diferente é a invisibilidade se condenam
as pessoas que amam iguais têm um
resultado honroso imaginam que um casal
do mesmo sexo que vivem junto durante
muitos anos quando morre o patrimônio
que foi construído juntos não fica por
parceiros
ele não consegue muitas vezes nem à
tarde em casa depois do inter fica com a
roupa do corpo e para onde vai esse
patrimônio parentes distantes até primo
é o de lu e primo todo mundo tem muita
mais às vezes esses países que sempre
rejeitaram que nunca conviveram com esta
pessoa também quando um sexuais têm
filhos gente homossexual tem filho
o adota o uso dessas técnicas modernas
de reprodução assistida
essas crianças acabam sempre registradas
ou adotadas por um aquele que vai se
candidata à adoção e não diz qual é a
sua orientação sexual é que aquele jogo
de faz de conta
mas conta que não sei só que o estudo
que é feito não é feito com o
companheiro ou a companheira daquele que
vai adotar ainda tenha sido uma
deliberação do pa
ou seja não é bem feito depois a criança
vai morar numa casa onde já tem dois
pais ou duas mães só que só um é o pai
ou a mãe
essa criança não tem nada não tem
direito até o nome do outro não tem
direito a se ele morrer ganhar era ansa
se eles se separarem ter direito a
alimentos ou direito à visita e se morre
o adotante esqueçam tem ninguém paga tem
que voltar para um abrigo
esta forma de tentar naturalizar as
coisas enfiando tudo pra baixo do tapete
para dentro do armário gera isto e eu
fui a primeira mulher a ingressar na
magistratura do estado do rio grande do
sul
foi uma guerra
é um horror
a gente se sentir não bem vinda não
conquista não desejar
e essa discriminação que houve para o
ingresso da mulher um poder e também nos
julgamentos nas leis e abracei todos
aqueles que a sociedade não dá voz nem
vez ea justiça fazem de conta que não vê
acabei me especializando em direito de
família porque ali que tem discriminação
sempre contra a mulher e fui abraçando
muitas bandeiras de uma forma
surpreendente
me dei conta trabalhando lá com as
questões de família que famílias de
pessoas do mesmo sexo nunca tinha
trabalhado com nenhuma onde estava não
eram família eram vistas e as suas
questões trazidas ao judiciário eram
jogadas para ceni
sou vidas como uma sociedade com se as
pessoas fossem sócias e património que
amealha sim sim se divide a medida da
participação efetiva de cada um e como
sócios não eram parentes quando um sócio
morreu e outro só ficava com aquilo que
comprovar e como é sócios não são
parentes não ganha nada nem pensando em
herança nem ficar residindo direito real
de habitação na
eu falei tanto eu gritei tanto eu me
movimentei tanto que a justiça começou a
enxergar ea reconhecer direitos a esses
vínculos que eu até crie uma palavra
nova uma afetividade heteroafetivo idade
pra que mostrar que os relacionamentos
não são na ordem da sexualidade são na
ordem da afetividade
se há uma relação afetiva
há que se reconhecer as
responsabilidades que daí decorre é
quase a frase pedras dos sonhos do pr
você é responsável porque em cativos e
deste movimento a justiça acabou
trazendo julgamento dessas nesse
processo para serem julgados pelos
juízes de família então se começou a
reconhecer que a família então tem
direito à herança têm direito à pensão
por morte
tem o direito dos filhos que eles têm ou
que a tottenham se qualifiquem para
adoção ser registrados no nome dos dois
é a única forma de por exemplo essa
criança ter direito a aas inserida no
plano de saúde do pai
viajar com um outro o qual outra mãe e
os avanços foram tantos até que no ano
de 2011 o supremo tribunal federal
acabou reconhecendo o direito ao
casamento no brasil homossexuais casa
tem seus filhos ainda não podem ser
registrados no nome dos dois
a não ser que entre com a fama justiça
direitos conquistados só por decisões
judiciais
é importante mas não é tudo
nós precisamos mais nós precisamos de
uma lei até porque lei tem caráter um
pouco pedagógico
está escrito na lei e depois assim a
justiça consegue conceder direitos
a justiça não consegue é unir
criminalizar a homofobia esses delitos
de ódio que acontece em nós a quando sai
no jornal já é uma notinha pequeno de
tão freqüentes que são esta este avanço
no entanto da justiça que eu confesso
que num primeiro momento acreditei bom
isso vai ficar de um número tão
significativo eu já criei um site e
todas as decisões do brasil colocando lá
dentro sabe quando eles não de saber com
essa consolidação legislador vai acabar
pa
regulamentando aprovando alguma
legislação 20 anos projetos para a
concessão de algum tipo de direito
tramitaram no nosso congresso nacional
nenhum chegou a se discutido que dirá
aprovado
nós temos um imobilismo o pior
nós temos uma rejeição am com quase a
sua estrutura porque a presença desse
fundamentalismo conservador está tomando
conta da sociedade dos meios de
comunicação é claro que as nossas casas
legislativas
os únicos projetos que tramitam agora
são para retirar o direito de voto vêm
sendo concedidos pela justiça mas se
fazer justiça foi o que me levou pra
dentro da magistratura também foi o que
me levou pra fora da magistratura e eu
acabei me aposentando e abre primeiro
escritório no brasil que botou na placa
no cartão de visita tem uma porta aberta
eu trabalho com direito homoafetivo tem
as portas fechadas não tem direito na
ale
resultado tudo é que vão saber
pode buscar algum direito e se brinque
portas vão bater eu abrir uma porta
fiz mais fui à ordem dos advogados no
dia que recebi a minha carteira que se
quer que sejam criadas comissões e
diversidade sexual para os advogados se
capacitarem para trabalhar com este eu
acho um novo ramo do direito
consegui a criação de uma comissão
nacional então só presidente da comissão
nacional da verdade só jacqueline umas
300 comissões brasil afora e fizemos uma
comissão científica que elaborou um
projeto de um estatuto da diversidade
sexual junto com as condições junto com
os movimentos sociais trazendo pra
dentro deste projeto
tudo que a justiça vem definindo e
também transformando a homofobia em
crime mas como fácil é tu decides
avançar entregar pra quem vai adiantar
até hoje nunca adiantou então de uma
maneira confesso que delirante as
comissões resolveram vamos apresentá lo
por iniciativa popular
se a lei da ficha limpa no brasil passou
assim é assim que vai ser mais fácil
aqui uma questão de cidadania e
começamos nessa louca busca de adesões
para esse projeto precisa ter no mínimo
1% de adesões de eleitores
isso significa quase um milhão m um
número muito perverso muito grande eu
comum sabe se o time está achei que isso
seria fácil não é a dificuldade que as
pessoas têm de sofrer em adorno ou se
colocarem no lugar do outro ver que esse
é um movimento de cidadania e que todos
precisam aderir porque afinal de contas
todo mundo é diferente
ninguém por isto é desigual
isso nós estamos em busca de cidadania
num país que se diz democrático de
direito
nós precisamos mudar esse eu comecei com
alguma música também vou acabar com
caetano veloso toda forma de amor vale a
pena toda forma de amor vale a marca